[Music]
the Spaniards arrived in Shalako near
the entrance to Tenochtitlan that was
the end of the March for they had
reached their goal
Mitaka Zuma now arrayed himself in his
finery
preparing to go out to meet them the
other great princes also adorned their
persons as did the nobles and their
chieftains and Knights they all went out
together to meet the strangers they
brought trays heaped with the finest
flowers the flower that resembles a
shield the flower shaped like a heart in
the center the flower with the sweetest
aroma and the fragrant yellow flower the
most precious of all
he presented many gifts to the captain
and his commanders those who would come
to make war he showered gifts upon them
and hung flowers around their necks
he gave them necklaces of flowers and
bands of flowers to adorn their breasts
he set Garland's of flowers upon their
heads then he hung gold necklaces around
their necks and gave them presence of
every sort as gifts of welcome when
mater Kazuma had given necklaces to each
one Cortes asked him a user king is it
true that you are the king mater Kazuma
and the king said yes I am
mater Kazuma then he stood up to welcome
Cortes he came forward bowed his head
low and addressed him when mater Kazuma
had finished La Malinche translated his
address into Spanish so that the captain
could understand it Cortes replied in
his strange and Savage tongue speaking
first to La Malinche tell mater Kazuma
that we are his friends there is nothing
to fear we have wanted to see him for a
long time and now we have seen his face
and heard his words then he said to
mater Kazuma we have come to your house
in Mexico as friends there is nothing to
fear
[Music]
this video is sponsored by Magellan TV
the documentary streaming service here
it voices of the past we give you the
raw source without comment Magellan is a
great choice if you want more context
delivered in a highly enjoyable way I
myself live in Spain so have been in a
pretty strict lockdown since early March
so as you can imagine I have pretty much
watched everything a good recommendation
that touches upon the old world clashing
with the new is Pocahontas and John
Smith an exploration of the truth by the
romantic story that has built up over
the years John Smith in fact is a source
that I may be looking at in coming
videos for those of you that haven't
signed up yet Magellan is essentially a
Netflix for documentaries with the
widest range of History content
available anywhere along with a lot of
other genres for example space which
dovetails nicely with our new channel
the entire history of the earth so if
you're trapped inside like me click on
the link in the description for an
exclusive month-long free trial for
voices of the past viewers thanks the
spaniards examined everything they saw
they dismounted from their horses and
mounted them again and dismounted again
so as not to miss anything of interest
when the spaniards entered the royal
house they placed mater Kazuma under
guard and kept him under their vigilance
then the Spaniards fired one of their
cannons and this caused great confusion
in the city the people scattered in
every direction and they fled without
rhyme or reason they ran off as if they
were being pursued It was as if they had
eaten the mushrooms that confused the
mind or had seen some dreadful
apparition they were all overcome by
terror as if their hearts have fainted
and when night fell the panic spread
through the city and their fears would
not let them sleep in the morning the
spaniards told mata kazuma what they
needed in the way of supplies doc Diaz
fried chickens eggs pure water firewood
and charcoal mata Kazuma ordered that it
be sent to them the Chiefs who received
this order were angry with the king and
no longer revered or respected him but
they furnished the Spaniards with all
the provisions they needed food
beverages and water and fodder for their
horses when the Spaniards were installed
in the palace
they asked Mata kazuma about the city's
resources and reserves and about the
warriors and Shias they questioned him
closely and then demanded gold Mata
kazuma guided them to it they surrounded
him and crowded close with their weapons
he walked in the center while they
formed a circle around him when they
arrived at the treasure house called del
calcio the riches of gold and feathers
were brought out to them ornaments made
of quetzel feathers richly worked
shields disks of gold the necklaces of
the idols Gold nose plugs gold Greaves
and bracelets and crowns the Spaniards
immediately strict the feathers from the
gold shields and ensigns
they gathered all the gold into a great
mound and set fire to everything else
regardless of its value then they melted
down the gold into ingots as for the
precious green stones they took only the
best of
a Spaniard searched through the whole
treasure-house questioning and
quarreling and seized every object they
thought was beautiful
next they went to mati kazuma storehouse
in the place called tata palkó where his
personal treasures were kept the
Spaniards grinned like little beasts and
patted each other with delight when they
entered the Hall of treasures It was as
if they had arrived in paradise they
searched everywhere and coveted
everything they were slaves to their own
greed all of Mata kazuma's possessions
were brought out fine bracelets
necklaces with large stones ankle rings
with little gold bells and all the royal
finery everything that belonged to the
king and was reserved to him only they
seized these treasures as if they were
their own as if this plunder were merely
a stroke of good luck and when they had
taken all the gold they heaped up
everything else in the middle of the
patio
[Music]
the Mexicans were too frightened to
approach they were crushed by terror and
would not risk coming forward they shied
away as if these spaniards were wild
beasts as if the hour would midnight on
a blackest night of the year yet they
did not abandon the Spaniards to hunger
and thirst they brought them whatever
they needed but shook with fears they
did so they delivered the supplies to
the Spaniards with trembling hands then
turned and hurried away the aztecs
begged permission of their king to hold
the Fiesta wid Cielo pottery the
Spaniards wanted to see this Fiesta to
learn how it was celebrated a delegation
of the celebrants came to the palace
where Mata Kazuma was prisoner and when
their spokesman asked his permission he
granted it to them on the evening before
the Fiesta of Tosh cattle the celebrants
began to model a statue of
Huitzilopochtli they gave it such a
human appearance that had seen the body
of a living man if they made the statue
with nothing but a paste made of the
ground seeds of the Chuvalo day which
they shaped over an armature of sticks
when the statue was finished they
dressed it in rich feathers and they
painted crossbars over and under its
eyes
early the next morning the statues face
was uncovered by those who had been
chosen for that ceremony they gathered
in front of the idol in single file and
offer the gifts of food such as round
seed cakes or perhaps human flesh but
they did not carry it up to its temple
on top of the pyramid the procession
began and the celebrants led into the
temple patio to dance the dance of the
serpent when they were all together in
the patio the songs and the dance began
those would fast it for twenty days and
those who had fasted for a year were in
command of the others they kept the
dancers in line with their pine ones if
anyone wish to urinate he did not stop
dancing but simply opened his clothing
at the hips and separated his clusters
of Harran feathers the great captain the
bravest warriors danced at the head of
the lines to guide the others the youths
followed in a slight distance some of
the youths wore their hair gathered into
large locks a sign that they had never
taken any captives others carried their
headdresses on their shoulders they had
taken captives but only with helmet
then came the recruits who were called
the young warriors they each captured an
enemy or two the others called to them
come comrades shows how brave you are
dance with all your hearts
at this moment in the Fiesta when the
dance was loveliest and when song was
linked to song the Spaniards were seized
with an urge to kill the celebrants they
all ran forward armed as if for battle
they closed the entrances and
passageways all the gates of the patio
the Eagle gate in the lesser palace the
gate of the cane stalk and the gate of
the serpent of Mirrors they posted
guards so that no one could escape and
then rushed into the sacred patio to
slaughter the celebrants they ran in
among the dancers forcing their way to
the place where the drums were played
they attacked the man who was drumming
and cut off his arms they attacked all
the celebrants stabbing them spearing
them striking them with their swords
they attacked some of them from behind
and those fell instantly to the ground
no matter how hard they tried to save
themselves they couldn't escape some
attempted to force their way out but the
Spaniards murdered them at the gates
others climbed the walls but they could
not save themselves those who ran into
the communal houses were safe there for
a while so were those who lay down among
the victims and pretended to be dead but
if they stood up again the Spaniards saw
them and killed them the blood of the
warriors flows like water and gathered
into pools when the news of this
Massacre was heard outside the sacred
patio three great cries went up
mexicanos come running bring your Spears
and shields the strangers have murdered
our warriors the cry was answered with a
roar of grief and anger the people
shouted and wailed and beat their palms
against their mouths the captains
assembled at once as if the hour had
been determined in advance they all
carried their spears and shields then
the battle began the Aztecs attacked
with javelins and arrows even with the
lights pierce they used for hunting
birds they hurled their javelins with
all their strength and the cloud of
mists
spread over the spaniards like a yellow
cloak the spaniards immediately took
refuge in the palace they began to shoot
at the mexicans with their iron arrows
and to fire their cannons and our
cabooses and they shackled mata kazuma
in Chains the mexicans who had died in
the massacre were taken out to the patio
one by one and inquiries were made to
discover their names the fathers and
mothers of the dead wept unlamented the
mexicans were enraged because the attack
on the captain had been so treacherous
the Warriors had been killed without the
slightest warning now they refused to go
away or put down their arms the royal
palace was placed under siege the
mexicans kept a close watch to prevent
anyone from stealing in with food for
the spaniards they also stopped
delivering supplies they brought them
absolutely nothing and waited for them
to die of hunger a few people attempted
to communicate with the Spaniards they
hoped to win their favor by giving them
advice and information or by secretly
bringing them food but the guards found
them and killed them on the spot after
they had trapped the Spaniards in the
palace
the Mexicans kept them under attack for
seven days and for 23 days they foiled
all their attempts to break out they did
everything they could to make the
causeways impossible they also closed
off the roads by building walls and
roadblocks
they obstructed all the roads and
streets to the city for days after the
people had been forced from the temple
the Spaniards tossed the bodies of Mata
kazuma and it's go out sin who had died
on a place near the water called TOI och
place of the divine turtle and when the
people saw and recognized who they were
they hurried to take Mata kazuma and
brought him to a place called cocoa
there they placed him on a wooden pyre
and set fire to it the fire began to
crackle and burn with many tongues of
flame and mater kazuma's body lay
burning and it smelled like scorched
meat and it let off a foul stench as it
burned at midnight the Spaniards in
tillich scale takis came out in closed
ranks the spaniards going first and the
Telex take us following the allies kept
very close behind as if they were
crowding up against a wall the sky was
overcast and rain fell all night in the
darkness but it was a gentle rain more
like a drizzle or a heavy deal the
Spaniards carried portable wooden
bridges to cross the canals they set
them in place crossed over and raised
them again they were able to pass the
first three canals without being seen
but when they reached the fourth their
retreat was discovered the first alarm
was raised by a woman who was drawing
water at the edge of a canal she cried
mexicanos come running they are crossing
the canal our enemies are escaping when
they heard this cry the Warriors are
lept
into the boats and set out in pursuit
the boat men paddled with all their
might they lashed the water of the lake
until it boiled the boats converged on
the Spaniards from both sides of the
causeway and the Warriors loosed a storm
of arrows at the fleeing army but the
Spaniards also turned to shoot at the
Aztecs they fired their crossbows and
their our cabooses the spaniards aunt
LUKS caretakers suffered many casualties
but many of the Aztec warriors were also
killed or wounded when the Spaniards
reached the canal of the Toltecs they
hurled themselves headlong into the
water is think they were leaping from a
cliff
the canal was soon choked with the
bodies of men and horses they filled the
gap in the causeway with their own
drowned bodies those who followed cross
to the other side by walking on the
corpses when the Spaniards left
Tenochtitlan they asked X thought they
had departed for good and would never
return
therefore they repaired and decorated
the temple of their God sweeping it
clean and throwing out all the dirt and
wreckage while the Spaniards were into
La Scala
a great plague broke out here in
Tenochtitlan it began to spread during
the thirteenth month and lasted for 70
days striking everywhere in the city and
killing a vast number of our people
sores erupted on our faces our breasts
our bellies we were covered with
agonizing sores from head to foot the
illness was so dreadful that no one
could walk or move the sick was so
utterly helpless that they could only
lie on their beds like corpses unable to
move their limbs or even their heads if
they did move their bodies they screamed
with pain a great many died from this
plague and many others died of hunger
they could not get up to search for food
and everyone else was too sick to care
for them so they starved to death in
their beds
[Music]
and now the Spaniards came back again
[Music]
the first battle began outside either at
the ash pits or the place called the
point of the olders our warriors put the
enemy to flight and not a single Aztec
was killed
the Spaniards tried a second advance but
our warriors attacked them from their
boats loosing such a storm of arrows
that the Spaniards were forced to
retreat again Cortes however moved his
headquarters just outside the city heavy
fighting ensued but the Aztecs could not
dislodge him finally the ships a dozen
in all came and anchored Cortes went out
to inspect the canals that traverse the
causeways to discover the best passage
for his fleet he wanted to know which
were the nearest the shortest the
deepest the straightest so that none of
his ships would run aground or be
trapped inside the Spaniards now decided
to attack Tenochtitlan and destroy its
people but the cannons were mounted in
the ships the sails were raised and the
fleet moved out onto the lake the
flagship led the way flying a great
linen standard with Cortes his coat of
arms the soldiers beat their drums and
blew their trumpets when the ships
approached the show qui upon quota the
common people were terrified at the
sight they gathered their children into
the canoes and fled across the lake
moaning with fear and paddling as
swiftly as they could they left all
their possessions behind them and
abandoned their little farms without
looking back
our enemies seized all our possessions
they gathered up everything they could
find and loaded it onto the ships in
great bundles they stole their cloaks
and blankets our battle dress our tables
and drums and carried them all away when
the spaniards reached shallow koh near
the entrance to Tenochtitlan they found
that the indians had built a wall across
the road to block their progress they
destroyed it with four shots from the
largest cannon when the Aztecs
discovered that the shots from the Aqua
buses and cannons always flew in a
straight line they no longer ran in the
line of fire they ran to the right or
left in zigzags not in front of the guns
if they saw that a cannon was about to
be fired and they could not escape by
running they threw themselves to the
ground and lay until the shot had passed
over them the Warriors also took cover
among the houses darting into the spaces
between them the road was suddenly as
empty as if it passed through a desert
the brigand teens came up and anchored
nearby they had been pursuing our canoes
into the open lake but when they had
almost run them down they suddenly
turned and sailed towards the causeway
now they anchored a short distance from
the houses as soon as their cannons in
the boughs were loaded again the
soldiers aimed and fired them at the new
wall then the Spaniards debarked and
filled in the canal working hurriedly
they threw in the stones from the
shattered wall the roof beams and bricks
from the nearest houses anything they
could find until the surface of the fill
was level with the causeway then a squad
of about 10 horsemen crossed over it
they galloped to and fro scouting both
sides of the road they raced and wheeled
and clattered back and forth soon they
were joined by another squad that rode
up to support them the spaniards now
joined all their forces into one unit
and marched together as far as
the Eagle gate where they set up the
cannons they had brought with them the
Spaniards wasted no time as they loaded
and fired their cannons the smoke
belched out in black clouds that
darkened the sky as if night two were
falling the Warriors hidden behind the
columns broke from cover and fled those
on the rooftops climbed down and ran
after them when the smoke cleared away
the Spaniards could not see a single
Aztec then the Spaniards brought forward
the largest cannon and set it up on the
sacrificial stone the priests of witzy
reportedly immediately began to beat
their great ritual drums from the top of
the pyramid the deep throbbing of the
drums resounded over the city calling
the Warriors to defend the shrine of
their God but two of the Spanish
soldiers climbed the stairway to the
temple platform cut the priests down
with their swords and pitched them
headlong over the brink the heaviest
fighting began when they entered na na
Falco
none of our enemies and none of our own
warriors escaped harm everyone was
wounded and the toll of the dead was
Grievous on both sides the struggle
continued all day and all night
the Aztec warriors advanced to the
sounds of flutes they shouted their war
cries and beat their shields like drums
they pursued the Spaniards harried and
terrified them and at last they took
fifteen of them prisoners the rest of
the Spaniards retreated to their ships
and sailed out into the middle of the
lake their captors quickly plundered
them seizing their weapons their cotton
armor and everything else until they
stood naked then they were sacrificed to
the god while their comrades on the lake
watched them being put to death the
Spanish blockade caused great anguish in
the city the people were tormented by
hunger and many starve to death
there was no fresh water to drink only
stagnant water and the brine of the lake
and many people died of dysentery
nothing can compare with the horrors of
that siege and the Agony's of the
starving
we were so weakened by hunger that
little by little the enemy forced us to
retreat little by little they forced us
to the wall it was at the same time that
the Spaniard set fire to the temple and
burned it to the ground the flames and
smoke left high into the air with a
terrible roar the people wept when they
saw their temple on fire they wept and
cried out fearing that afterward it
would be plundered step by step the
Spaniards gained more ground and
captured more horses they forced us
backward along the a mashach road with
their Spears and shields
Cuauhtemoc consulted with a group of his
captains then cooled in a great captain
named a pot Jetson who was a dire by
trade they dressed him in the finery of
the quetzel owl which had belonged to
King half-wit Sacco
then Cuauhtemoc said to him this regalia
belonged to my father
the great warrior outwits awful terrify
our enemies with it uh nyle ate our
enemies with it
let them behold it and tremble the king
ordered four captains to go with the pot
shots in as a rearguard he placed in the
captain's hand the magic object there
was the most important part of the
regalia this was an arrow with a long
shaft and an obsidian tip the captain
Talcott sin said mexicanos the power of
wit sila poached lay resides in this
finery loose the sacred arrow at our
enemies for it is the serpent of fire
the arrow that pierces the fire loose it
at the invaders drive them away from the
power of Huitzilopochtli but shoot it
straight and well for it must not fall
to earth and if it should wound one or
two of our foes then we shall still have
a little time left and a chance to
conquer them now let us see what the
God's will may be the quetzel owl
departed with the four captains and the
quetzel feathers seemed to open out
making him appear even greater and more
terrifying when our enemies saw him
approach they quaked as if they thought
a mountain were about to fall on them
they trembled with dread as if they knew
the finery could work magic
the quetzel owl climbed up onto a
rooftop when our enemies saw him they
came forward and prepared to attack him
but he succeeded in driving them away
then he came down from the rooftop with
his quetzel feathers and his gold
ornaments suddenly the battle ended
neither side moved against the other the
night was calm and silent with no
incidence of any kind on the following
day absolutely nothing took place and
neither the Spaniards
nor the Indians spoke a word at
nightfall that began to rain but it was
more like a heavy dew than a rain
suddenly the omen appeared blazing like
a great bonfire in the sky it wheeled in
enormous spirals like a whirlwind and
gave off a shower of sparks and red-hot
coals some great and some little it also
made loud noises rumbling and hissing
like a metal tube placed over a fire it
circled the wall nearest the lakeshore
and then hovered for a while from there
it moved out into the middle of the lake
where it suddenly disappeared
no one cried when this holman came into
view the people knew what it meant and
they watched in silence nothing whatever
occurred on the following day our
warriors and the Spanish soldiers merely
waited in their positions
Cortez kept a constant watch standing
under a many colored canopy his officers
stood around him talking among
themselves the Aztec leaders gathered in
Tommy akin to discuss what they should
do Cuauhtemoc and the other nobles tried
to determine how much tribute they would
have to pay and how best to surrender to
the strangers then the nobles could
quiet a mock into a war canoe with only
three men to accompany him a captain a
servant and a boat man when the people
saw their chief departing they wept and
cried out our youngest princess leaving
us he's going to surrender to the
Spaniards
the Spaniards came out to meet him they
took him by the hand to let him up to
the rooftop and brought him into the
presence of Cortez
the captain stared at him for a moment
and then patted him on their head then
he gestured towards a chair and the two
leaders sat down side by side
[Music]
you